this is a production of cornell
university
thank you for the introduction
so
first i will give a
quick
click
a few
background slide slides for
uh for my talk and then i will proceed
to
introduce our recent finding
in the environment of ecupouring in
aluminum resistance
and heavy metal detoxification
yeah finally i will give a quick summary
for some of my recent
ongoing project in the lab
so introduction
plan requires
essential nutrients for their survivor
and
growth
the essential nutrients can be
classified into two groups the basic
non-mineral and mineral nutrients
the basic non-mutual uh non-mineral
nutrients
are supplied to plants through
air and water you can see carbon
hydrogen and oxygen
and
while the mineral nutrients come from
the soil
mineral nutrients can be classified into
macros and micronutrients there are six
macro and seven micronutrients
so you see the micronutrients many of
them are transition metals so that they
have a very narrow
dynamic range
between requirement
and toxicity
so for instance carpal
iron magnesium and zinc they all
transition metals
there are also metals and metalloids
with no structural
and cellular functions
but they can be toxic to plants under
certain environmental conditions for
instance like aluminum cadmium arsenic
etc
the soil provides plants with essential
nutrients however plant can encounter
soil based abiotic stresses these
include
drought flooding
mineral deficiency
high salinity
or heavy metal toxicities
adverse ph conditions either too low or
too high
so all these abiotic stresses can
inhibit plant growth
and development
leading to
year losses
so my laboratory research is focused on
heavy metal toxicity and
low ph or
acidic soil
related stresses including including
low ph stresses and
the aluminum stress is associated with
the low ph
for
non-accumulating plants they take
two general strategies to cope with
metal
toxicity
the first strategy is an
exclusion mechanism
with these mechanisms plant roots reduce
organic compounds to the rise of sphere
forming non-toxic
complex with the toxic ions in the rice
of spheres which cannot enter the root
cell so that's the
how the exclusion happened
the second strategy is the so-called
internal mechanisms
which deals with toxic metal ions
in the plants
in general plants move
the toxic ion away from the most
sensitive part of the plant
or sequest sequester the
toxic metal ion into the vector
of the root cells or
leaves their or above ground of the
above ground tissue
also different metal ion toxicity
has
different target for instance
aluminum toxicity target at the root
especially the blue tape region
so in conscious zinc toxicity
targets at the shoe like a leaf
so this the second section
the involvement of echo pouring in
aluminum resistance and heavy metal
toxicity
so first i would like to introduce
aquaporin aquaponics another name is
water channel
so it constitutes a large and
evolutionarily
conserved family implants
for instance there are 35 members in
arabidopsis
based on their subcellular localization
and function
the members can be further classified
into at least four
subfamily so including
the plasma membrane
intrinsic protein or pips
tango plus intrinsic protein tips
largely 26 like intrinsic protein
nibs
and small basic intrinsic protein sips
aquaporins are channel proteins that
facilitates
the passive transport of small molecules
across various
cellular membranes
it is generally believed that
acupuncture
facilitates
polar but not
facilitate the transport of polar but
non-charge the small solutes
so such as water
carbon dioxide
ammonia
arsenic boric acid etcetera
so it's still an argument whether
echo porting can
transport
charge the metal ions
so i will talk about uh more on this
issue so in my next uh
talk
so first echo powering and aluminum
resistance
first i i will introduce
what is aluminum toxicity aluminum
toxicity occurs when the soil ph is
below
5.0 or i mean it's acidic
soil
under this condition the toxic
aluminum ions or al3 plus
is released from the soil particles
which is highly toxic to the roots
especially to the root tip region so
here shows two wheatline one
tolerant cholesterol and the sensitive
uh
aggregate so you can see under the
neutral soil
condition
they both are defined they they are
healthy no no difference but under
um acidic soil condition you can see the
root growth
uh was greatly inhibited by the uh acid
big soil
so this inhibits the roots
grows in limits water and nutrition
uptake
so that's the reason i mean the plant
you see the stumping plant and loss of
yield
so in arabic
the plants maybe take the exclusion
mechanisms to cope with aluminum
toxicity so which is uh achieved by
uh root release of
malic acid
and citric acid from
uh from the roots
and this process
can you remove
yeah thank you
yeah so these are two transporters
uh amt1 stands for aluminum melee
transporter
is responsible for
melee release from the root tip and
atmade is a signal transporter
it's responsible for the release of
situations from the more mature
shoot i mean the root
region
so the question is whether an
internal detoxification mechanism is
involved remains uh
unclear in arabic arabidopsis
so the next how was aquaporin linked to
aluminum transport and resistance
so before i proceed i would like to
introduce the concept of aluminum
accumulator
so
in nature
most the plant species including crop
species
are so-called non-accumulating plants
which means they cannot tolerate
high concentration of aluminum or other
toxic metal ions
in their above ground tissues
but there's a small number of plant
species including carb species
they can accumulate high levels of
aluminum in their above ground tissues
without showing any
uh toxicity symptoms so these include
are several quite narrow plant species
like tea is a accumulator
but buckwheat also and flour i mean the
hydrangea
so the hydrangea plants
are interesting
okay
so um in that they have
red and blue
colored flowers
amazingly i mean the
color difference is not depends by
genetic variation
by environmental factors
so specifically it's the soil ph
so under neutral soil ph
uh condition the plant produce red
flower
but if you switch the plants to uh
low ph or essex oil the flower color
turns from red to blue
so
so like just like a magic
so how can
so
this one no
what should i
why
okay okay yeah
should we go back yeah that's fine yeah
the fact that i've just finished
so how can
ph
change the color of hydrangea flower
this the answer is aluminum
so under the neutral ph soils
the car i mean the the flower shows the
native red color
of the enterthing stored in the vacuum
over
of the
sea pulse so what we see here is
actually separate but not paddle of
other common flowers
so under acidic soil condition
alumina is released from the soil and
taken up by plants
and translocated to the above ground
tissue and finally uh sequestered
into the bacteria of the sepal cell
so the
aluminum there will
form a new complex with the enterthing
turning the flower the new uh complex
it's blue color so this is the secret
for the magic
so dr kumi yushida's lab in japan they
are working for the
horticulture trade and they study
uh the the mechanisms underlying the
flower color change in hygiene gear so
using a differential
expression approach they find two genes
that encode the proteins
that are responsible for
aluminum uptake and color change
in the
sepal cells so these two proteins
one is called port
stands for plasma membrane aluminum
transporter
and watt stands for vacuolar aluminum
transporter so these transporters are
responsible for
uh taking up aluminum
across the plasma membrane into the
cytosol
and
further sequester into the vacuoler
both port one and water one are members
of the echo pouring gene family
in hygienia
so for us working on aluminum resistance
so the natural questions could echo poor
remember
be involved in aluminum resistance
implants
so to address this question we did a
phylogenetic analysis and found out that
the
nips members are the closest homologue
of the
port one gene in hydrangea
so next we we are
examining the
phenotype of the individual
uh
for individual members
their mutants and see their performance
under
a luminous gases
so that's what the summary i mean we saw
that the nip 1-2 mutants are more
sensitive to
aluminum toxicity so under the
standard condition root growth of the
wild type and the nip 1-2 newton cannot
be distinguished so that's that means
this gene is not essential for
normal function but under aluminum
stresses we can see the uh
more growth inhibition in the mutant
compared with the wild type so this
result indicates the relative function
of nipple 1-2 is involved in aluminum
resistance
so we further characterize the
subcellular localization of map 1-2 when
expressed in east as well as the uh
native pen root cells
the
nep1-2 grp
recombinant protein
it was localized to the plasma membrane
suggesting that the uh
the protein is a
plasma membrane localized the protein
yeah further we characterize their uh
transport activity
in the
modern east systems what we found that
is that the
nip 1-2 is brushing east
expressing each cells
facilitate the aluminum uptake activity
when
the
median
was supplied with
aluminum
melee
i will not see any
uh optic activity
with the aluminum ion or aluminum ion
conjugated with uh different
cellular ligands this suggests i mean
the
aluminum mainly it's a transport subject
for
nip 1-2 can you tell us what the cell
type is there
what they mean tell us what the cell
type is
is that the root cap
so
what is the cell type in the thesis the
plant roots what is what cell type is
cell type this is the yeast
wouldn't the plant root cells
this one yeah
this is the root cell yeah those roots
there root tip in the root type region
is that the root cap
or another root
um
so in one centimeter so within the one
centimeter of the root tip
it's not root cap yeah so so it could be
uh
particle sales or i mean
yeah that's and and
it's an overexpression of 35 so it's
everywhere i mean we just want to
see the general idea how the protein
where the protein is localized
okay
and next we use a yeast system to
uh
further characterize
the transport activity
for nip 1-2 and this is the time course
influx and e-flash access as we can see
nip 1-2 facilitate
net aluminum uptake
activity and also net
e-flat activity in for the east cell
this results suggest that nip 1-2
it's a bi-directional
aluminum
melee transport transporter
yeah this slide summarize how
the systems work
and this shield a
longitudinal
section
of the root
uh
section
so the left
is the soil and rhizosphere and this
part is the
plant
root cells
and the open area stands for the
root
apple plastic or root cell wall and then
circles
indicate the plasma membranes of
the epidermal cortical endoderm
pericycle parenchyma plasma membrane
under low ph condition
aluminum ions
are released from the soil which can
freely enter the root cell
so in the root cell uh blue cell wall i
would say i mean
in the root cell world
the aluminum ion directly activates the
male transporter or amt1
leading to the release of melee from the
to the
root cell wall
which can also
be
diffused to the rhizosphere
so in the rhizosphere as we are as in
the root cell wall region aluminum and
malay
conform a complex aluminum melee complex
this complex is non-toxic to plants
plus
they cannot enter the roots so that's
how the
exclusion mechanisms work
so previously people thought oh the
melee and
aluminum complex is non-toxic to plants
and plants has no way i mean to
like speed down like animal right to
push away the the compound to the soil
so they thought that's not toxic but in
our case we found that
based on our mutant analysis
so this compass indeed are toxic to
plants and need need to be further
removed from the root cell wall and the
root cell is one of the most sensitive
target
for aluminum toxicity
so this is achieved by
the
nip 1-2
transporter
so it
removes
aluminum melee from the root cellar into
the
cytosol and
through the thin plastic flow it can
further move to the parenchyma cells
where
explode
proceed to the
silence
they are facilitated by nip 1-2 so this
is an e-flat activity so it also fit for
the bi-directional
transport activity of this uh protein
so in this uh model we see two
components one is uh amt1 the magnetic
transporter the other one is the nib 1-2
so it's a uh
aluminum transporter right so what's the
advantage for the junkie function of
amt1 and nip 1-2 so we know amt1 is the
most important aluminum resistant genes
in arabidopsis it accounts for
80 percent of the aluminum resistance
in the species
so however i mean the
melee release
and spending it it costs carbon and
energy right i mean malay is an
important carbon source for the plants
so however i mean the
lip 1-2 is a channel and it just uh
passively
transport
the the substance across the plasma
membrane it doesn't need energy so with
the addition of nip 1-2 we can see
15 percent increase in
root growth under
aluminum stress
condition
so
the coordinated function
of amt1 and mit1-2 can increase top and
use efficiency for aluminum resistance
so the next topic is comparing and heavy
metals
subsequently with zinc
zinc is an essential micronutrient for
all plants however excess zinc is toxic
to
non-accumulating plants
like arabidopsis
the symptoms of zinc
toxicity include astounding shields
levels
root growth inhibitions so but mainly
the shield is the primary target for
zinc toxicity in arabidopsis
so for players
to cope with the
toxicity
so
maybe involve the
internal
detoxification mechanisms
yeah specifically like i think
immobilization
in the root as i mentioned before i mean
uh
the general
rule of thumb is like
move the toxic metal ion eye ions away
from the most sensitive part to the uh
and keep in the
uh
non-sensitive part and
zinc positive target at the shoe so
plants need to keep the
zinc in the root which is less sensitive
right
and so the result is
less thing will be translocated to the
shoots
the second uh
important step is to
transport that
excess link inside the cell into the
vacuum over so this is also a very
important
mechanism for detoxification
so we have now i mean there are several
a few
panoplas transporter responsible for
length detoxification so this including
ntp1
and rep
3 and 4. so our question is
are there other transporter involved in
this process
so
we hypothesized that tip members of
the acupuncture family
could be involved in zinc sequestration
in arabidopsis
so the direction now is that the
thermoplastic transporters facilitate
vacuora zinc sequestration
and the members of the tip sub families
are localized to the tonoplast
so to test this
hypothesis again we analyze
mutant lines for
individual
members of the tip sub family and we
found out that the tip 2-2 mutants
are
more sensitive
to elevated zinc concentration
compared with the wild type
also in this slide i include several
very no
mutants they are hypersensitive to zinc
toxicity including pad 2-1 and cat 1-3
and t-p-1
so this
suggests i mean the water function
of
2-2 is involved in zinc detoxification
yes we study the zinc distribution in
wild-type and mutant plants
we look at the zinc content in the root
shoot
and silence that as a as well as leave
leave trichomes
so as we can see under the standard
condition
uh so two micromolar zinc there's no
difference
in
uh
root
in zinc concentration
for the wild type and
the built-in plants
in all tissue or samples exams however
under elevated zinc concentration here
is like a 60 micromolar in
hydroponic solution we can see
significantly lowered zinc content
in the mutant plants compared to the
wild type
but in contrast we see higher
concentration of zinc
in the shoots and silence that
so this results indicate that the mutant
plants
could not retain
or defect in the retention of
high-level zinc in the root so that more
uh
toxic zinc is translocated to the
uh shoot tissue so here
and also we measure the uh zinc content
in leave trichomes
surprisingly and
the mutant
contains less zinc content in the
tritone charcoal is also an important
organ for
heavy metal detoxification so it's in
considered as external organ for plan
so this results indicate that tip
2-2
facilitate zinc immobilization in the
root and
sequestration in the
tripod
then we further
look into the distribution
of zinc in the root cells so we know the
mutant plants retain less zinc in the
uh in the root right but it's because
less zinc concentration in the root cell
wall or in the root
cell
everything exclude the root cell right
lose their wall so here is the uh zinc
concentration
in the root cell wall
and root cell set root cell step is
everything except for the root cell wall
so what we can see it's uh in the
for the root cells that cell wall we
cannot see difference between
the wild type and the mutant but the
mutant
contains significantly
less zinc concentration in the root cell
set this result indicates that the
tip dash 2
2 2-2
facilitate sync transport into the root
cell but not just keep all them in the
new cell wall
so tip 2-2 expression
it's induced by
elevated same concentration as in both
roots and shoes
and amazingly
the expression it's
uh
suppressed by
saying the depletion condition as
showing here the time course
uh type 2-2 expression
so we see significantly
reduce the level
so with the uh
as a function of
time
treatment
of zinc depletion
so this results indicate that type 2
dash expression
is determined by
zinc status
of the plan
so we must test the
expression pattern
for
mrna and also for the subcellular
localization
of the protein so we see the
gas activity
mainly localized on the uh the root root
region so that's from
the root elongation to
mature root region and also
the
protein is localized to the plasma
membrane
because it's
the uh
tip 2-2 gfp
fluorescent it's overlapped with a very
very well-known
turner plus marker tip one dash one so
this for of link with the rfp
so we further caterpillarize
tip 2.2 function in the model e-systems
so before i uh
proceed i would like to introduce the
four primary zinc transporter
in
east
so there are two
two of them are localized on the plasma
membrane so that's 31 32 so encoding for
high and low affinity
zinc transporter
and also two zinc transporters on the
thunderplast so that's like one and
caught one
so the third one caught one facilitate
zinc sequestration
from the cytosol to the uh vacuoler
so
if this two critical transporters on the
tunnel plus
is deleted what happened under
aggravated zinc concentration
so we can see the zinc will be taken up
by the plasma membrane localized
third one and third two and we'll see
the accumulation of zinc in the cytosol
but the cell lacked the function
for sequestration of the toxic zinc into
the vacuole as a result
each cell would be
extremely
sensitive to
elevated zinc concentration
so we can use this system to test
function for tip 2-2 so our prediction
is that if tip 2-2 is a zinc protein and
it's localized to the plus
tonoplast
so it will be
[Music]
rescue or complement or partially
for the
hypersensitivity phenotype
of the
z1k1 double mutant
under the
zinc toxicity condition
so we expressed a um
tip 2-2 gfp fusion protein in the
circ-1 carte 1 background what we can
see here so this fusion protein
is localized to the tonoplast
yeah and then we test the uh
zinc resistant phenotype
so this the uh circuit one cut one
mutant
with a empty vector or expression
tip 2-2 we can see under the standard
condition
so the growth
of
both lines cannot be distinguished
so however under elevated the same
concentration 60 micro molar thing it's
not too high but you can see that
the double mutants with the vectors
show
very strong growth inhibition
but the east line expression
tip 2-2
shows partial
complementation for the phenol mutant
phenotype
so
yeah okay cool
so let's we we uh treat the cell
with um
with bso bso is a important
gsh biosynthesis in inhibitors so with
these inhibitors we see that uh
elimination of the
partial complementation of the
tip 2-2 lines
so this results yeah i see there's no
difference i compare with this one
this results suggest that gsh above
synthesis is required for tip 2-2
facilitated
uh zinc transport
and sequestration to the vacuum of the
yeast cell
so in summary of this part so
our results indicate
or suggest that type 2-2 facilitate a
zinc sequestration to the bacteria of
the root cells
and also immediate the zinc
immobilization
in the root so that last zinc is
translocated from the root to
shoot tissues
so in conclusion uh tip 2-2 it's a
critical player
in zinc resistance
and detoxification in therapeutics
so the next the last part of this
section is
aquaporin and other heavy metal
toxicity
so i don't have
much time stuff for for this project is
still going on and just show you several
uh
photos indicating that
so we identified some
mutants for the
uh in the aquaporin family uh
that are
hypersensitive to
cadmium
and also to
niko nico is also essential
micronutrient for for plants
so more workers are
still going on
so in summary for my thought echoporin
are generally
believed to facilitate
transporting polar but non-charged small
solutes and metalloids
so our findings provide
several lines of evidence indicating
that
some echo program members
could involve in
metal ion trans transport and resistance
so further studies are required to
elucidate the nature and function
of the ion conducting echoporins
so last slides i would like to give a
quick summary of
some of
other ongoing research in my laboratory
so first one is the aluminum resistant
project with two resistant gene in the
weed and and
normal
aluminum resistant mechanisms
in mate so i have a uh give a
plan
breathing seminar in early spring of
this year so this is the uh youtube link
so uh in this video there's more
detail
uh about these two projects
so and also i have we have a stop one
it's a mutant hypersensitive to
uh low ph so we've identified several i
mean that's many suppressors so this is
a good project to
study the mechanisms underlying
low ph stresses
and also we are involved in
identifying or
elucidate
the pain hormone and there are roles in
plants resistant to
low ph stresses so i think this uh
all
could be a good opportunity for
graduate students and
hostel also
so
so with this so this end of my talk i
would like to thank
my uh current and former lab
members
and also my collaborators
listed here
so i only have a few
minutes
left so i would like to stop here
and
thank you and thank you all for your
attention and i would like to
answer questions
do aluminum and zinc
permeate the membrane in a hydrated form
oh i cannot hear
um
zinc and aluminum permeate the membrane
in a hydrated form
or a dehydrated form
yeah so so this is a i know you are
uh question underlying i mean
so
the this is very complex question i mean
they
it's very difficult to see study the uh
chemical form of like aluminum and zinc
i mean inside the cells i can say i mean
the echo problem we have many
circumstantial um
evidence
so for instance think it's
for zinc
gash complex
so it's probably a neutral charge so we
need more direct evidence to to make the
conclusion
yeah let me ask you one more question
do you think awkward porn
um is a misnomer it has been a misnomer
from the very beginning
when martin chris peels used it to
describe water genius
uh
so i i didn't catch you up do you think
did you think the
function that the
natural selection has given that protein
that's called aquaporin
selective advantage for transporting
water
or is its real function
for transporting other kinds of things
oh yeah i mean this is a great question
so so there are so many members of
aquaporin so with
so there's many many studies in the case
besides uh water
so echo potting can also transform many
like small solutes including like carbon
dioxide ammonia
uh
boric acid right so that does many and
still many acupuncture members functions
are not clear
so only a few of them has being
characterized
so that's very diverse i mean that's art
so one thing that's interesting
almost everything you mentioned will not
permeate through a lipid membrane
through the lipid part of the membrane
a transport protein
water on the other hand will permeate
through a lipid membrane
conductance is small the ear is huge
so
um the lipid membrane actually
transports probably half of the
water so the selective pressure for
water movement would be
my new
for acroporas
yeah i mean this is a good question i
mean that's not still uh
uh the magnesium is not very clear i
mean for echo pouring there's two uh
constriction regions so that one is mpa
constriction region
and also ar
constriction region or
selective filters
the people that mean that's critical for
uh solid selectivity
but
obvious i mean this is not the only
component that determine
the sub uh substrate selectivity
so there's still many unknown
questions left
for echocardiogram
let's
family
and yeah i cannot hear very clear where
they are
tip 2-2
it's conserved at the level of orthology
and other species um and i'm curious we
have a rootstock we work with that
protects the scion from accumulating um
heavy metals green zinc
oh yes i mean that's definitely a good
question so my answers are we don't know
yet i mean we just look
in arabic arabidopsis i haven't looked
at other species but i can give you
another sample it's like uh nip i mean
that's for aluminum so it was uh
identified we identified in arabidopsis
but now we are working in the weed so
definitely i mean that's the mechanisms
it's conserved between the mono top and
diet
species so we are hoping using this
knowledge obtained from apopsies to
improve our aluminum resistance and
yield for the wii
yeah
so yeah i i i yeah i guess it's the uh
the answer but i i have no evidence here
so uh i have a question about the uh the
nips
so can you hear me
uh it's yeah you speak a lot with the
mess i mean that's always there you just
said you know the nips 1-2 is the five
direction bi-directional transporter
right so i don't know if the direction
is depend on the
position you know of the cell or just
concentration of the
the concentration of the material
yeah i mean this uh very common for
the nip members
they are
functioning as a bi-directional
transporter so there's many other
evidence so for for other nip members so
for instance for
um
for for the
arsenic transporter so it's also
facilitated by a few members in the nip
family so they're all bi-directional so
maybe it's a common
feature for
for for for this
uh
gene family yeah i mean you know
according to one of your slides
uh it shows the direction you know the
the aluminum method compound they should
basically transport from out you know
from the environment
inside the epidermis cell and then just
go
all the way to the xylem right so this
is one direction so is there any
possible that you know the aluminum just
goes with outside from the xylem to the
bar
uh if the concentration of the aluminum
environment relatively low or something
like that
because it's by function of
bi-directional
uh transport transportation right so
yes i mean the um
nip 1-2 or other like other
channel proteins
they are passive channel i mean
transport
substrates
uh
based on the
uh
concentration gradient
so it's just like a past i mean like a
gate i mean it's not a an active so i
think that's
uh i mean this is the factor you need to
keep in mind maybe
the root uh
epidermal cortex they are closer to the
rice of sphere so that has more chance
for the aluminum
get into so they have higher
concentration that can
so so these all uh
found the uh
concentration gradient so so that's what
all right thanks
okay yeah hi ross
sarniel so for the uh with the 2-2
transports we talked about facilitation
of zinc from the cell wall
to the cytosol right
so presumably
but the wall itself the polysaccharides
can complex very large amounts
so do you incorporate that into your
analysis
yeah i'm very sorry i cannot hear very
clearly
or really yeah oh yeah yeah yeah that's
you so so that's what i asked to
wear a sheet instead of a mess because
uh the previous seminar got a lot of
complaints about uh
yeah
so if you can oh i can go closer so that
i can speak really loudly okay so i'm
asking do you know how much of the
aluminum or zinc is complex into the
cell wall itself so it's not freely
mobile it's complex with pectins that
polysaccharides
balance
is that very very much in in
your analyses okay so i don't know
exactly
uh how much if i can show that maybe
probably
yeah i mean that one we just measure the
zinc content in the cell wall versus the
cell set that's all we have now that's
all the knowledge we have yeah
yeah so i think the amount that can be
bound when it separates an amount that's
freely mobile can vary a lot so that
would be interesting yeah
the apoplastic fluid with the cell wall
balance components oh yeah yeah that's
could be yeah yeah definitely yeah
one more question
yeah oh one more
um
i also want to refer to your
model about tonight yeah speed up
your model
and aluminum resistance
your model has
said
it moves so you
you move the aluminum method from
outside to the inside
have you seen that
nip one is uh localized poorly in any
type of cell or is it just everywhere on
the memory
oh you mean the gene
uh protein localization or expression
yes it's in the root tape i mean that's
we measure i mean uh examine the
expression pattern
for both nib 1
2 and amt you mean i mean that's the two
like a partner so
the expression patterns overlaps
so it is quite uh consistent with their
function
they work
coordinated i mean actually uh the
amt1
it's epistadic to nipple 1-2 we have a
independent
started indicate that so so
um yeah i mean i would say i mean
the expression patterns
in the same
position of the
rules
like whether it localizes to one part of
the cell more than the other part
one part of the cell wall
uh i think that's the uh
you
you mean i mean
uh
so there's a casparian right in the root
root uh region i think that's everything
outside the cell wall
um
as long as there's a uh
hip 1-2 expression i mean
it will like
move the aluminum
melee complex from the cell wall into uh
into the cytosol
yeah
time for one or two more questions from
zoom
uh okay yes one what happens does it
know what happens to the aluminum zinc
after it's transported to the vapors
well i think gsa's contributes to this
we have the alumni name depositing
yeah let me say thank you for looking
here
he entered the asylum okay okay good yes
after uh loading into this island it
will move to
um
to the shoots
uh based on the transparent just
respiratory
respiratory uh stream right i mean
that's all like water and many other
solute uh
are translocated in this way
i hope i answered your question i mean
that's i mean that's all
i'll go everything with others
all right let's all thank chipping again
for a great seminar
[Applause]
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu